les études scientifiques parlait de
pénurie énergétique
d'emballement climatique
d'extinction de vivant
c'est un véritable choc un
bouleversement après avoir vu le film
documentaire une fois que tu sais des
questions se posent des inquiétudes
émergent souvent les gens sont pas bien
voilà mais je dirais que ça dépend un
petit peu d'où on en est par rapport à
la conscience de ce qui nous attend en
fait se dire aussi que on a dépassé les
bornes vous faites quand on est allé
trop loin et qui a plus de retour en
arrière possible c'est ça en fait qui
rend mal à l'aise et qui rend très très
mal en fait les raisons de ces ressentis
le récit de l'auteur et réalisateur
emmanuel kaeppelin le spectateur est
plongé dans son esprit l'évolution de sa
pensée sur les sujets du réchauffement
climatique et de la préservation de
l'environnement
on parle de ce moment-là ou d'iphone
choc émotionnel énorme qui va libre
quand y va pour une raison
professionnelle être à bord d'un porte
containers et où il va avoir une vision
complètement apocalyptique de ce qui est
en train de nous arriver et moi je dis
accompagné pendant plusieurs années sur
la mise en forme de sept films deux ans
et demi de montage après cinq années de
tournage des séquences enregistrées
entre l'europe les états unis et le
bangladesh à la rencontre des
scientifiques et des spécialistes du
climat et experts du giec les ingénieurs
qui sont là pour en parler rich weinberg
qui est là pour parler de la fin des
énergies fossiles aussi qui est
spécialiste des énergies fossiles et des
villes en transition et son mât pour
poser ce constat ce film a reçu
plusieurs reconnaissances dans plusieurs
festivals internationaux chaque
projection est suivie d'une discussion
participative avec les spectateurs puis
un guide est distribué à la fin pour
rassurer et tenter d'agir face aux
conséquences du changement climatique
une fois qu'on sait qu'est-ce qu'on fait
collectivement
[Musique]
puis